bonjour je m'appelle fontaine Sébastien
j'ai 22 ans j'ai le PMI et je suis
véhiculé j'habite à petite île je
recherche un poste de technicien
informatique en lien avec la maintenance
informatique ou le développement web je
suis disponible sur
obtenu un bac STI génie mécanique en
2010 avec la mention assez bien suite à
cette formation j'ai effectué un BTS
Informatique et réseaux pour les
industries et les services en 2012
concernant mon expérience
professionnelle dans le cadre de mon BTS
j'ai effectué un projet
tutoré qui était la réalisation de
d'interface Java j'ai par ailleurs
effectué un stage dans un entreprise
métropolitaine qui s'appelle météo
stratégie en tant que développeur web
j'ai aussi
travaillé pour distribc pour la
configuration d'ordinateurs pour le
peuple j'ai un bon sens du relationnel
je suis rigoureux et autonome je suis
disponible pour répondre à toutes vos
questions et éventuellement pour un
entretien